con 75 votos a favor 41 en contra y 14
abstenciones la asamblea nacional cumple
así con la sentencia de la corte
constitucional que expuso la defensoría
del pueblo a la presentación de un
proyecto de ley que regule el acceso al
aborto en casos de violación y la
temporalidad para acceder a la
interrupción del embarazo la asamblea
nacional hizo una diferenciación de 12
semanas para mujeres que habitan en la
ciudad y para mujeres que habitan bajo
condiciones excepcionales en las zonas
rurales para niñas adolescentes y
mujeres de la nacionalidad indígenas de
18 semanas para la interrupción del
embarazo argumentando la falta de
métodos de salud de primera mano para
las mujeres que habitan en las zonas
rurales los profesionales de la salud
deberán confirmar que se encuentran
dentro de las semanas autorizadas para
realizar el aborto se establecen reglas
específicas en el caso de personas con
alguna discapacidad mental que deberá
contar con su aprobación y respetar su
voluntad los centros de salud deberán
contar con formatos de consentimiento
para que las mujeres que deseen
interrumpir el embarazo sean traducidos
al braille e idiomas kichwa y
herramientas tecnológicas adecuadas en
el caso de las mujeres con discapacidad
auditiva deberán contar con intérpretes
para acceder
de manera informada si existiera
conflicto de intereses y el violador
fuera el cuidador de la mujer violentada
la mujer podrá ser acompañada por otra
persona a su cargo los centros de salud
también deberán ofrecer los formularios
de atención idiomas ancestrales y
garantizar la información a mujeres de
la ruralidad las niñas y adolescentes
podrán consentir la interrupción del
embarazo de manera autónoma el ejecutivo
nacional tendrá 30 días para presentar
sus observaciones y promulgar la ley y
enviarlo así al registro civil para su
entrar en vigencia